wir schauen uns jetzt gemeinsam die
aktuellen zahlen mit verschiedenen
karten an dafür muss ich aber leider
sagen
die neuinfektionen die heute gemeldet
worden sind ein trauriger höchst rekord
noch nie wurden so viele neuansteckungen
wir heute an einem sonntag vermeldet und
das zeigt leider nur einmal wieder dass
der lok downlight nicht funktioniert hat
so jetzt schauen wir aber gemeinsam auf
die in neuansteckungen von denen ich
gesprochen habe 20.200 das ist die zahl
die heute an diesem sonntag vermeldet
wurde vom robert-koch-institut binnen 24
stunden das sind die neuansteckungen
letzten sonntag also genau vor einer
woche waren es 17 1700 und dazu muss man
sagen die zahlen am wochenende sind nie
vollständig denn die ämter übermitteln
nicht alle ihre daten am wochenende und
b wird natürlich auch nicht so viel
getestet
ja die nächste zahl ist die traurigste
sind die todesfälle binnen 24 stunden
heute wurden 333 tote menschen aufgrund
des corona virus gemeldet
am freitag hatten wir den traurigen
rekord hin haben wir gemeinsam erlebt da
waren es 6 104 tote menschen und um sich
diese zahlen vielleicht ein bisschen
besser vorstellen zu können um die etwas
besser greifen zu können
alle zweieinhalb minuten stirbt derzeit
ein mensch in deutschland an der
lungenkrankheit cupid 19 insgesamt gibt
es hierzulande bisher 21 1787
registrierte todesfälle im zusammenhang
mit dem corona virus und jetzt wollen
wir schauen auf die hotspots also hier
sehen wir ganz deutschland und sie sehen
es hier auch zur orientierung die farben
alles was hier in diesem ganz dunklen
rotes und in dem pink ist schlecht hier
sind sehr viele menschen infiziert auf
platz eins in deutschland ist wie in den
letzten tagen auch der landkreis regen
in bayern hier liegt der incidents
mehrwert bei 604 5
sieben auf platz zwei da hat sich auch
nichts verändert ist bautzen im
landkreis sachsen mit dem wert 574 13
und wir sehen ist hier auch direkt der
nachbar landkreis görlitz ist auch in
einem tiefen pink und auch hier das
liegt auch in sachsen der erzgebirgs
landkreis also sie sehen ist hier vor
allem in sachsen ein super corona
hotspot deshalb ab montag da steht schon
fest wird es den knallharte lockdown für
sachsen geben heißt nur noch supermärkte
und drogeriemärkte werden offen haben
egal was sich heute oder jetzt in den
nächsten stunden entscheidet dann haben
wir noch eine grafik die wir zusammen
anschauen wollen und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch die wichtigsten
zahlen denn darum kämpfen wir in
deutschland ja dass nicht alle
intensivbetten mit corona patienten
belegt werden wir sehen jetzt hier
aktuell gibt es noch 4061 freie
intensivbetten in deutschland 4496 sind
aktuell durch corona patienten belegt
und wenn wir uns die ganze karte
anschauen dann sehen wir auch dass es
überall gott sei dank noch freie betten
gibt
damit gebe ich zurück zu nele und paul
und bin selbst gespannt was jetzt genau
durchgesetzt wird und ob es eine
einheitliche linie für deutschland geben
wird
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren